talking a little bit about what we're
doing at our particular institutions and
then we'll leave it open for some extra
time uh for discussion specifically
wanted to lay out the format um while
we're talking if you have any like
really burning clarifying questions like
what did you mean by X you know feel
free to jump in then but otherwise leave
your um deeper questions to the end and
immediately following our third um
presentation what we actually want you
to do is to turn and talk with a
neighbor about the findings that we had
and what might have been interesting to
you or where you may have had similar or
Divergent findings so kind of keep that
in mind as we're talking that you'll
want to turn to a neighbor a little bit
then we'll have the kind of the typical
large group conversations but then we
also want to reserve the last five
minutes to synthesize a bit about what
it is that you want to take home to your
institution and apply tomorrow or Monday
so also keep that in mind so with that
in mind I'll go ahead and get started my
name is Jason Mock and I'm the lead
instructional designer for corsera
projects at the University of Illinois
orbana champagne and we have about eight
mukes live right now and another 12 or
so in development of which I'm involved
with most of them and the question that
I kind of have is you know what really
counts as a participant what does it
take to count someone as a participant
and another question might be what does
success even mean in a moo and I mean
that on multiple levels like what does
it mean for a student to be successful
in a moo what does it mean for the
institution to be successful in
delivering mukes in general or an
individual faculty member the rest of
these questions these are the kind of
questions that kind of keep me up at
night and what I want to try to do today
is lay out a stage of just kind of like
questioning how we answer these
questions and the ways in which we
answer these questions differently have
institutional benefits we all have our
own unique stories to tell but it also
makes it a little bit more difficult for
all of us to talk to one another as
researchers and practitioners in the
field so I may only ask questions and
not give answers if that's okay um so
one of the traditional metrics that oh
this formatting got strange but that's
fine um traditional metrics that we use
when we're talking about mukes is course
completion right it's kind of the first
easiest lowest hanging fruit metric to
judge a course by and it's also the C
the metric that we're used to judging
courses by in our traditional highered
courses so you'll often hear people
point to course completion As the metric
of choice or at least the first metric
that they look at in a moo and I want to
kind of talk about a few Pros but mostly
some cons of that particular approach um
this is how you might see it
characterized 4% of students pass the
class it's very generalized typical
number I know the numbers vary based on
who you ask but I want to decompact this
just a little bit um namely looking
first at that 4% that is a very low
number by traditional standards that's
one of the criticisms that mukes have um
Been Under Fire about because we're
comparing it to traditional standards I
think there's something to be questioned
there but really you know know even if
this whole statement were true 4% of
20,000 people is still 800 people and
that's that's a lot for any one class
for most for most institutions so even
at face value I think this could be a
positive
statement and then um let's take a look
at um the whole pie here so there's 4% n
that means 96% didn't pass the class and
is that a fair thing to say so to give
it a fresh perspective we start with the
piie of 100 total percent of
participants these are the people who
registered for the class anyway I'm
pretty sure that we were okay to get
started maybe some child has grabbed the
bell I don't know um that's what my kid
would do anyway um so we start with 100%
of all the people who registered for the
class and if we decompose that pie a
little bit differently than just say 4%
what we found at Illinois is that 44% of
the people never log into the Course
once they sign up for it there's no
barrier to entry in corsera you put in
an email address you click a button and
you're done but similarly there's no
real pressure to follow through on that
if it were an obligation to begin with
because you do not have uh tuition on
the line you're not moving halfway
across the country or the world to take
this class there's no real uh extrinsic
incentive to participate and so 44% of
them never even show up once so that
leaves the 56 that are left and of those
56 about a third 20% of the total
registrant we found were active only one
day essentially they logged in they
poked their head around and then they
never came back and in some ways that
can be viewed as a negative statistic I
think it's also possible that's a
success factor that 20% were able to
look at the course and very quickly
determine that it didn't meet their
needs maybe they could tell it was going
to be way too much work or the topic
wasn't relevant to them or what have you
so that takes those um people out we're
left with the last 36% now if we insert
that 4% wedge we see that 4% in the
context of only 32% it's about 11% of
the students pass the class and I'm not
trying to say that 11% is a really great
number I'm just trying to say that it's
all about how you look at the numbers
and what you put in the denominator so
at Illinois we put if you're active for
more than one day in the denominator and
we look at all of our metrics against
that so let's look at that statement
again for okay fine 11
whatever perent of students pass the
class still is a kind of a a negative
sounding phrase but I also want to kind
of decompact the rest of that phrase as
well when we call them students are we
implying anything about what we expect
them to do how we expect them to behave
when we call them students um just for
reference in corsera they have moved
away from using the term student and
toward the term learner instead maybe
there's something there and then passed
what does it even mean to pass a class
essentially passing still does come down
to earning a certain number of points
and how do you earn points by completing
certain activities with a certain
proficiency so in other words these
Learners are jumping through whatever
Hoops the instructor has put in front of
them but how well are those Hoops
aligned to the individual needs and
goals of the students um I'll come back
to that in a little bit and then if we
call it a class is that what this I
guess that's what the C and AO is
massively open online course but you
know for some participants they don't
view it that way uh I'm going to show
you some data about that a little bit
later so I think it's important to kind
of take this phrase the four or 11% of
students pass the class with a grain of
salt it has its place but I think it's
also U just the first step towards
analyzing success in a moo one thing I
want to point out is this is some data
that we gathered from our surveys about
why students took the course we asked
the open-ended question and then
analyzed hand coded a thousand other
responses and one thing that I find
interesting is down towards the bottom
get a certificate or credential is only
about 3% if I were to ask the same
question to the traditional students in
the credit bearing courses at my
institution I think that number would be
100% right they're not going to take the
course unless they're getting credit for
it they may check other boxes as well
but the point is we have very different
audiences when we look at the
traditional higher ed courses versus the
students who are taking these mukes and
I think we may want to design our
courses accordingly and we'll see that
why most people are taking this is
merely if you want to call it that to
broaden or extend knowledge or general
interest appreciation of the topic so
there's a very different motivation
different rationale behind the vast
majority of people who are taking these
mukes um but nevertheless we naturally
want to try to talk about mukes in
meaningful ways and so we do things like
4% of students pass the class we have
some baseline metrics there's a number
of studies and the formatting on that
got a little um funny I'm sorry but you
know different people trying to
categorize the Learners in these courses
and there's just these different
terminologies I'm not really wanting to
talk about them in particular except to
say that as a community we're all still
wrestling with this concept of how do we
put our hand how do we name what we're
seeing and we don't really know yet my
favorite is the grazers and Strivers I
think that one's kind of interesting
um and so I'm not here to propose what
the proper labeling is um but my one
observation about each of these labels
is that they're very linear and they
kind of um presume a progression towards
what somebody thinks is the best kind of
student um the most uh achieved student
in our courses and I kind of question
that a little bit and so I'm just going
to show you one and it it is nice
because it makes for pretty graphs but
um I want to show a slightly different
way of looking at it again this is is
not necessarily the right answer in fact
I'm only showing you one of the answers
that we have for purposes of
illustration and that is to say let's
not look try to use traditional metrics
of success and higher ed as the Baseline
but let's take a look at the data and
see what the data might suggest is
happening in the courses and then try to
name that and so we also want to
recognize that with the diversity of
motivations that graph that horizontal
bar graph I showed you before these
students are coming into courses with
very different goals and very different
definitions of success that they have
for the these courses and so that's what
we're trying to recognize in this so all
we're doing here is trying to take in
this case we put on the y- AIS the
percentage of total points earned how
many points they got in the score in the
course versus the number or percentage
of the videos that were watched and then
we do K means clustering to group these
into five bubbles now there's
intersection points all over this chart
but what we've done is we've filled
filtered it down to five representative
Bubbles and we see down in the lower
left corner that large pie wedge that we
saw on the the earlier graphs where
people are not really participating in
the lectures they're not really
participating in the quizzes we might
call that low level
achievement and then kind of in the
middle purple area uh where we see 20
30% of the total points scored 30 40% of
the videos watched you know that's
probably indicating that people are
making some progress through the course
and then they abandoning ship we see
that happen a lot a lot of previous uh
presentations today and yesterday
pointed that same effect and then we get
the three remaining bubbles that I think
are the interesting ones the top left
corner um is people who earned a lot of
points in the course but they didn't
watch any of the videos so that's a
little bit counterintuitive that's a
different form of success for them for
these students perhaps they already know
the material so they're not going to
bother taking the quiz the take watching
in the videos they're instead going to
demonstrate their knowledge via taking
the quizzes maybe they're looking for
credentialing maybe they just want to
like have that sense of accomplishment
without investing the time in the
lectures but for them my point is they
have success in the course without
taking the course in the kind of the
whole perspective that we might think of
first watch your lectures then do your
quizzes no they're skipping that to get
to their own form of success in these
courses bottom right the orange bubble
that's where we see that they watched a
very large L percentage of the videos
but they did not earn any of the points
on the quizzes and that's probably
because they're doing what they want to
do which is watch all the videos kind of
they really probably want to have a
YouTube channel in fact I kind of wonder
if maybe we should be making YouTube
channels to satisfy that particular
bubble rather than trying to force them
through the Hoops that we're trying to
push them through and then the top right
corner is the kind of the traditional
achievement category where they're
watching all the videos and they're
earning all all the points and they're
successful by our standards it just
happens to be that it's success by their
standards as well um what we see by the
way um is that the those three bubbles
of high achievement do have uh very high
satisfaction scores the other two
bubbles have some degree but obviously
not as much and so again my only point
is to say how we're trying to label
these students in their success really
drives a lot of our interpretations of
success of the moo as a whole but I
think if we just change the way we look
at it we might have different
perspectives
thanks okay um hi so I'm Hal do from the
University of Maryland uh this is going
to be a sort of brief overview of a
couple of things that we've done related
to student engagement uh it's joint work
with a bunch of students in postdocs um
who of course did the real work and then
uh also my former colleague Lisa who's
now at Santa Cruz um so uh a lot of this
is going to be a bit of a repetition of
what Jason said so this is uh this is
actually corsera data um from corsera so
this is basically just looking at uh
completion rate so the uh the red box is
sort of the you know two to four per of
uh students who actually succeed but the
interesting thing is that even if you
ask people in precourse surveys do you
intend to complete the course uh still
only about a quarter of those students
do um and so uh the the rest of the blue
bar uh the 75% uh we're going to call
the savable students um and uh and we're
going to try to figure out like uh what
can we do uh to keep them uh in the
course and uh and why did they drop so I
don't know why the coloring got funny uh
but there's this great thing from George
coup uh called the disengagement compact
uh which you can't read because most of
the words are missing but I highlight
highed some of them but it's basically
that uh uh students don't want to work
and instructors don't want to work and
so we have this compact that says you
know well I won't make you work too hard
if you don't make me grade too much and
so what we're trying to avoid is the
situation uh where where students don't
want to work okay so um all right I'm
getting very nervous about the
formatting at this point uh okay so uh
one of the things that we've looked at
is uh what people talk about in
discussion forums and I'll talk a little
bit more about what courses we're
actually using for uh for this later um
but here are some example quotes so uh I
think our values are shaped by past
generations and our fam as well
sometimes negatively um any sort of
off-the-shelf sentiment analysis will
tell you that negatively is a negative
sentiment word um someone else says what
I love about this video is how much
music influences social change so many
great songs can motivate change in
people in society so the Bold green
words are sort of the obvious positive
words uh then you get things like the
video was terribly jumpy I hated the
experience or this was a great course
learned a lot about genes and The Human
Condition um so the the sort of
observation is that there are two types
of sentiment that people can express um
the first two uh are course content
related um sentiment and the last two
are course Logistics related sentiment
and this is particularly important I
think when we talk about Humanities
courses so a lot of the data that we've
been working with is Humanities data and
uh and for instance the first quote here
is from a women's civil liberties course
where a lot of the discussion is people
relating their own personal experience
related to things uh about women's civil
liberties and often this will come with
a lot of emotional baggage that gets
uh displayed as negative sentiment but
if we treat sort of the negative
sentiment toward some topic the same as
negative sentiment toward the course
then we're sort of missing out on a lot
of the Nuance of what students are
talking
about um so I'm going to briefly say uh
how we try to model this um all of the
details will be missing of course um but
basically we're trying to capture things
about student Behavior so this is post
View and vote in forums um viewing of
lectures taking of assignments um we're
using structural information so do two
students Post in the same thread uh we
use linguistic information so what's the
subjectivity in the posts as well as
what are the topics that that
subjectivity is related to so not just
is this a positive or negative post but
is this a positive post about course
Logistics or is this a negative post
about some particular course topic um
and then also some temporal features uh
so the way that we do this is we use
this tool called probabilistic Soft
logic which lets you write these nice
little logic rules that say something
like um if Sophia posts something uh so
she has some post and this post has
positive sentiment then I'm more likely
to believe that Sophia will survive and
for survive for now we're just using the
notion of uh did they complete the final
assignment or not um and so these things
oops these things are not uh sort of
hard logic rules they're soft logic
rules um and the weights or sort of the
strength of these rules is learned
automatically from data um so basically
it's a convenient way for us to write
down things that we might expect to be
true
and then the Learning System can figure
out which of these actually help model
the data best um
so um so these are the sorts of things
that we have uh related to the the
sentiment and the post topic so in the
first one we say something like well if
Louise posts uh something and this
something is about logistics and he's
saying something negative uh then he's
less likely to survive uh the second one
says if flow post something that
something is on a general topic uh then
she's not likely to survive um so
basically if you're just talking about
sort of nothing rather than talking
about an actual course related topic uh
this isn't going to help you um the
third one says that if Shauna posts
something about the course and this gets
upvoted then she's more likely to
survive and then the last one is
correlating behavior between two
students so um if Shauna had this course
related post and she survived and Sam
had another post that looked like
Shauna's post then sea then Sam is more
likely to survive um so these are sort
of the the flavor of the sorts of things
that we're able to write down and
basically what we see is as far as this
um the survival prediction task uh this
helps sort of to varying degrees
depending on the course so we have the
women's civil liberties course which I
mentioned before uh this is a disruptive
technology course and this is genes in
The Human Condition which is basically a
non-technical um genetics course um and
so what we see is that there's you know
somewhat of a boost for adding uh the
sentiment features and then a larger
boost for having the topic specific
sentiment features and this seems to be
uh much stronger for these Humanities
like courses than for technical courses
so we also did this for the Stanford
machine learning course there the
sentiment alone was fine because no
one's talking about their experience as
a child learning about decision trees
and how decision trees had a positive or
negative impact on
them um okay so the other thing that we
did was we looked at trying to model
specific types of Engagement so this is
actually super related to the bubbles
that uh Jason was showing before so um
we're going to refer to students as
actively engaged or passively engaged so
these are basically the upper left
corner students and the lower right
corner students in Jason's picture so
the actively engaged students are ones
who post positive things uh so Mario
makes a post this post is positive so
we're going to say that that makes him
more likely to be actively engaged um on
the other hand um if there's some post
that's positive and Koo upvotes it uh
then we're going to say that she's
passively engaged so she's sort of
lurking I mean she's actually clicking a
button but she's not actually typing
something um and then we're going to
have sort of this combination rule that
says basically if you're in both of
these categories so if you're in Jason's
top left bubble and bottom right bubble
you're more likely to be in his top
right bubble um so if a dit is both
positively and uh is both actively and
passively engaged he's more likely to
survive um and so this is the same sort
of result that we saw before the effects
here are actually quite strong so the
yellow bar here is if you just try to
predict survival based on number of
lecture views um so this this does very
badly for the disruptive technology
course it does okay for the genes and
Human Condition course um and then the
the the orange bar is basically what
happens uh when you just directly model
the survival as a function of the input
variables rather than trying to model
the two different types of Engagement
and so the difference between the orange
bar and the blue bar is how much gain
you get by trying to directly model this
distinction between active and passive
engagement
um and for instance in the women civil
liberties course this makes just an
enormous
difference um so I wanted to spend my
last minute uh just saying a word about
the sorts of things that we're looking
at now so my background is not an
education uh my background is in natural
language processing which is why I'm
particularly interested in discussion
forums um and so one of the things that
we've been looking at uh over the past
several months is uh trying to use
discussion forms as a way of fostering
and increasing the amount of knowledge
building discussion that you get um
especially in these Humanities courses
but also in technical courses uh so
there was a there was a great couple of
papers by vong Chen at University of
Minnesota um where he handc coded both
uh discussions made by K through eth
graders as well as discussions on
corsera um into various things that I
would call uh dialogue
States um so when people say things you
can say well are they questioning are
they theorizing are they obtaining
evidence um are they just sort of
offering
opinion um and then by looking at the
sequence of dialogue turns uh that
different students take in a discussion
you can try to predict whether this
discussion is knowledge building or not
so um bong's uh uh results basically
said that effective discussions uh have
more theorizing they tend to integrate
use of information so for instance you
theorize for a while then you obtain
some evidence then you theorize some
more um ineffective discussions have
lots of opinion giving uh this sounds
like uh faculty meetings to me um and so
what we're working on now is how to
detect these things automatically rather
than having to go in and hand code them
one by one um but sort of in the limit
it's not really enough to detect these
what we want to do is intervene and
actually try to pop the knowledge
building discussions up to the top uh so
that students really know what they can
look at they can engage in the material
um and hopefully have more of a
um I don't want you say the word engage
again uh more of a personalized
experience in the course all right
thanks
okay so um I am the uh third person for
this panel talk um and it's only fair
that my two co-panelists all experienced
some you know technical difficulties not
intended so it's only fair that I also
had some you know technical difficulties
so that's you know expect where I would
be expecting that kind of thing um so uh
my name is Al Wang uh I'm from Columbia
Teachers College um I work with
Professor Ryan Baker's on educational
data mining lab um so following the uh
the string that Jason had talked about
some really high level engagement and uh
motivation issues and then um hel also
talked about um his case and especially
he touched upon the discussion forum
analysis um and sent analysis and I
thought about I should be the third one
uh not because I might be the shortest
you know presenter for um this session
but also um I will focus on one specific
case study um focusing on one specific
moo um so a quick outline even for a 5
to seven minute talk um I'll give you
some research context and also methods
and Analysis and third part will be just
overview and reminding of what our major
findings are that can be helpful for you
guys
um so this one single moo uh we worked
on is called Big Data in education we
collected all the keywords and hot words
you know Big Data education so we're
both practitioners and researchers in
this
field um this course was offered only
once up until now uh last year from
October 28th to December 26th and these
are a few bullet points of what we
covered in this
course and uh similar to the majority of
the early corsera courses uh our course
components are pretty common we have
videos assignments discussion forums and
study
groups uh this is a quick interface um
we have PowerPoint slides and a Talking
Hat um very enthusiastic you know
instructure as you can
tell um and this is some quick facts
about um an early course survey we um
designed I wanted to emphasize this is
an early course survey so it's not a
pre-course survey we specifically uh
distributed this survey after we
released the first week
materials so students can have at least
some taste of what they're going to be
Eng engaging with and from this survey
um we we had responses from students uh
coming speaking at least 106 different
languages well um before I um advance to
you know the the fors the data I also
wanted to ask myself and you know all
the audience members what could be you
know some of the resour questions we
should ask ourselves both as researchers
and
practitioners um of course our top in
panel is on motivation and we want to
know different aspects of motivation how
do they correlate with course on
completion and after that we can ask
ourselves what can we know about Mo
completers and non-completers what are
some of the differences or
similarities and later on of course we
all wanted to enhance our
you know interface design to give our
students A Better Learning
Experience so a quick survey overview um
we have um amassed alog together over
48,000
registrants um at at the first week and
we only have 638 students completed the
course so the completion rate is not so
promising but I want to emphasize that
um what kind of student population we're
talking here what is our research
designed for we might not want to you
know enhance all the Muk Learners
learning experience all at once how
about you know the completers and
non-completers or even survey
respondents or maybe the more engaged
students what we want to know more about
them
um so in this survey it's actually
really short survey students only need
to take about five minutes to 7 minutes
to complete it and we included three um
types of variables to try to measure
student motivation and the first
category we selected 10 items which were
used in some early research studies to
to to ask students why do you take a moo
course
specifically and the second category we
selected uh a p two pal motivation sub
skills to measure mass go orientation
and academic ethicacy um if you want to
learn more you can uh go online and just
type in Pals and University of Michigan
I'll give you the full scale of what
their uh what their surveys are designed
for and we also include the one item we
just simply ask the students um in the
first week you know how confident do you
think you will be able to finish the
course according to the PACE set by the
instructor
um and we found that because we we want
to know the differences between um
course completers and non-completers and
then we found there are sign statistic
significance significantly difference uh
between um completers and
non-met completers um for the 10 items
um we call that Muk specific items um
and
okay so I had the same issue that it's
supposed to be one two three of course
um and self reading skill is also
another good indicator to say um whether
you will be a good uh completer or
not and to uh control for multiple
comparisons and we use the Q values to
in place of um P
values and this super text Heavy graph
just you know trying to tell us was that
the P scales we
selected um did not really show
significance between uh non-completers
and completers this is actually pretty
consistent with our hypothesis that we
think that um both completers and
non-completers they're all voluntarily
signed up for mood courses so they
should be both High uh in terms of
academic efficacy and be Mastery
oriented
um
so sorry so in this graph um we also
listed um the items I said in the first
category that we measure uh M specific
items and the the ones highlighted all
showed statistic uh significance between
the completers and
non-completers and I'll explain uh why
they can be interesting to be grouped
together I'm going to skip this this is
the pal items
um so the self-re is confidence is
actually pretty good indicator um so if
we ask a student where you what would
give them the scale 1 to 10 let them to
self read themselves uh how confident
you are to complete a course and if you
are confident in the beginning and then
you are more likely to finish the
course so uh just a quick review of what
I just touched upon
um
so I I said about the remember the first
category the items I um I mentioned the
there the questions we ask you know um
whether you think a geogra
geographically located in a remote area
is um an important thing for you to take
the course and whether you think a moo
platform as a new platform is an
interesting um thing be so that that
really motivate you to sign up for the
course that kind of thing so um all the
items showed up significant are all
items students who show that they're
more interesting in the novelty of the
Muk platform rather than the content
itself and of course you know that the
two pal scales were trying to measure um
Mastery go orientation and academic
efficacy are not really great indicators
if we want to know the differences
between completers and
non-completers and the third one is
the self-reported confidence um is a
pretty good indicator if you wanted to
ask your students in early in the course
when used still have you know quite
promisingly um at least around like
several hundred students will respond to
you uh you can get a quick idea of
whether they would actually finish the
course or not and there's a fourth one
um we also did an interesting test on
the two survey items of the two group
groups of not completers and
non-completers but uh the English speak
uh English native speakers and non
English native speakers and we look at
the differences on their self-reading
score on you know early in the course
whether they can complete or not before
they actually you know start the second
week of the course and very
interestingly that the non-english
native speakers self-re it higher um in
their completion confidence than native
speakers uh we're not exactly sure what
are the reasons behind it but we were
thinking about there are two possible
reasons that number one is if you are an
English learn English language uh
learner you might have you know
experienced more learning opportunities
just because you want to learn English
from from the you past years so you
might have msed great learning skills by
just learning English another reason is
some of our students we actually get to
know them they they told us that one of
the reasons they want to take our course
is not just because they wanted to study
stats machine learning programming but
they wanted to improve their English
it's a fantastic opportunity for them to
you know to be able to even join
discussion forum to test whether their
language can be understood by a student
from New
York um some of the next uh plan plan
studies we wanted to do is we want to
connect our variables we got from the
early course survey uh with other
metrics such as you know um the log
analytics log data which uh we just got
from
corsera um and of course the other
components such as discussion forums
quiz completion rate video usage uh uh
and also of course like um engagement
navigation
patterns um
we're also trying to well some of some
of our colleagues in Colombia and other
other universities approached us and
they want to use the same survey in
their courses so we expect to
reimplement the replicate studies with
them to try to say whether there's any
disciplinary differences between our
course and their
courses um and one of very exciting
course um that I really want to
recommend is an upcoming adex course
um it's called data analytics and
learning um I'm going to show you a
graph in the next page um another thing
I'm also really excited about in the
next stage we want to conduct a little
longitudinal study to try to measure um
the impact after taking a moo we want to
know whether students you know after
taking a moo have went on to say submit
a paper uh joined an academic conference
um or whatever they did because of you
know taking our course um so we're
looking forward to see some of the
findings in there and this is the course
uh I did a screenshot of addex um I
would urge you to all you know sign up
right now um for really great um
university professors from for
institutions and Professor Caroline Ros
is sitting here um it's going to be a
great course in Ryan Baker on Dragon
guest and of course the famous George
Simmons um another sort of a little um
self-promotion um Professor Ryan Baker
make sure that uh I mentioned that he
has already put up all the learning
materials on his personal website um
meaning that everything you can get from
the corsera interface all the
videos um all you know the slides the
papers uh The Learning Materials if you
go to this website you can access them
without you know establishing any like
loging password you can just watch it
and do
it um this is also you know a very
simple um I don't want to use the word
design it's just a web page but it's
also a course and it's called massive
online open
textbook um and if you want to follow us
um we were potentially going to reoffer
also reoffer this course in a
traditional Muk setting meeting in addex
next year in January um this is our LA's
Twitter
handle and thank you very
much so I'm going to do the honor of uh
try to initiate the uh discussions so we
three actually tried really hard to get
to know each other because we didn't
really know each other before this panel
and then we actually went on to have a
Skype call and everything and say like
we need to get know each other's studies
and then have to work on this thing
together so and one of the things
popping up is we wanted you guys to have
at least something to take away not just
say like and we went to your
presentations and then nothing really
stayed in my mind or really helpful so
we asked ourselves to listed some you
know key points and takeaways from our
presentations I'm not going to read that
uh you can just you know look at them um
kind of like as a quick reminder of what
you just have heard us to talk over like
30 minutes
and after that we're going to do this um
discussion and then Jason you want to so
if you could just you know take a couple
of minutes and turn to someone near you
and if you're kind of isolated then you
know go find someone to become near to
you and just talk about what we talked
about namely but also in your own
context you know where where are you
doing similar research or where have you
found maybe um conclusions that differ
from what we have and so just take a
couple of minutes to share amongst
yourselves and then we'll open it back
up to the larger group
thanks
AF wor
Tech
instru the to
be
about one more
minute about one more minute about one
more minute about one more minute thank
you
yeah
there's I think you're
okay
all right well I hope that I know that
that was probably a short amount of time
for most of you to get to know one
another a little
bit it's so exciting we can't even stop
talking oh I feel
bad we'll have more time I promise right
after we uh leave this session before
going to the town hall continue these
conversations what I'd like to do is
actually these great conversations that
are happening among two or three people
I'd like each of your groups just to
throw out one or two things that you
learned about from your discussions uh
as a group or something that you struck
you about our conversations but we want
to just kind of take the next 10 minutes
we're going to reserve the last five
minutes for a different activity take
the next 10 minutes just to share any
insights that you have and there's the
two roaming mics if you can raise their
hand these guys are good about getting
it to
you sorry what's her name again Rene
Renee hi uh I'm Chen from uh MIT and um
in our group um with Chris and Renee
here uh we what what what um what we
found is that we're placing too much of
an emphasiz emphasis or too much of a
bias on
completers people who completed the
course gets a certificate I've been in a
lot of mukes and I've always been that
96% unfortunately um yeah I've been in
Ryan Baker's course and I didn't finish
I spent about a week so it's a very bad
data point but I mean in many of the
courses I audited I completed some of
the assignments I learned something
and I was saying that uh um if if you we
are a business and we're only focusing
on 4% of our customers we have a really
bad business model um and so so so I'm
just
starting to think that um we should
really uh Focus to on understanding
these people who come in learns part of
does some part of assessment learn some
part of the videos uh how do they value
this perception and Renee here just told
me they published a paper on uh uh on
pretty much the similar issue and and
says that people who didn't complete the
course like the course almost as much as
people who completed that right
I suppose one thing to to to qualify is
uh I mean one of the points you make is
placing a a value judgment uh you know
you had these greater than equal signs
right and we when we wrote the the
deconstructing disengagement paper where
we really wanted to get rid of the
notion of completers and non-completers
and look at how people actually behave
and try and characterize that uh we were
struggling with whether we should Place
some value judgment on what is better
than than something else uh and we ended
up just doing it a little bit because we
felt that if learning is the ultimate
goal that these these uh device does the
Muk serve right and at this conference I
think we we uh we we hope so then then
doing assessment retrieving knowledge as
we learned again and again at this
conference should be uh of of a should
be encouraged in some sense right so
that's why it's
tricky I'll just have a really quick
comment adding on that um I completely
agree with both of you that completion
rates is not the so indicator or not
even the primary indicator for measuring
success in mood learning environment but
then again when we were you know uh
brainstorming about what kind of
research we want to do there are two
reasons we wanted to choose course
completion uh number one is it is we
have to admit the most popular most
talked about metrics in universities
institutions and all kinds of areas and
that's one of the easily accessible
metrix that we should not um Overlook
and number two is I personally thought
of you know the way to you know separate
the completers with non-completers is
not to say we want to judge you because
you did not complete a course but more
interestingly we want to know about this
interesting population that's been
filtered through our course we want to
know how on you know like these kind of
students they have their own lives and
jobs and and of course our courses is
not the the best course ever giving you
all kinds of support and we all as
faculty members we all make mistakes and
this there's something wrong that's
something wrong
but despite all these you know students
there are 4% 1% or whatever percent of
them actually persisted and completed
the course and you if you think about
that it's it's really something amazing
and we want to know I want to know also
you know like what's giving them the
strong motivation to complete the course
and what's really distinctive for you
know that that just people in general
can learn from them can get from them so
that's one of the motivation for us to
you know separate the completers and
non-completers more thoughts yeah
well one of the things we were talking
about um is um the Mastery goal uh
orientation scale and I was we were
interested in that um because um I've
actually run items from that scale as
well so uh I guess I wanted to share
that we had a few significant results of
that not focusing on retention actually
um we're on the third iteration of
running a composite scale that includes
items of you know Mastery approach
orientation but also um some other
scales but the Mastery items were and
and they're tricky you know tricky to
take these subscales and very tricky to
deploy them right and find the the
strongly loaded items that like people
will interpret the same way um so we we
were on the third iteration of this we
ran it in a Muk we also ran it in a
couple Blended classrooms at UCSD and at
UCLA um and in the more more slightly
more like you know real life classroom
Blended classrooms it was predictive of
completing the course but in the moo it
was predictive we were focusing more on
other things like of um engagement right
so students with higher Mastery
orientation they were more excited about
the class they liked it more they were
more talking about sharing it with other
people stuff like that so um I guess
that's one of the things we were
chatting about was just why it would be
Works in some ways and maybe not work in
other ways but certainly research in
this area is challenging any other
thoughts uh I actually yeah uh hell do
you do I have my your name right or yeah
so I wanted to share a few Thoughts with
you you know being in a you know similar
work and trying to learn you know sort
of similar things to what you're trying
to learn um you know the truth is what
we're seeing from the intentions data
that we're starting to get from
different platforms is that the truth is
more than 50% of students who enroll in
Mooks uh self-report that they intend to
complete the course at the beginning uh
so you know I wanted to basically share
two two thoughts quickly the first is uh
when you mentioned the idea of a manable
versus non amenable student groups uh
it's you know the there
literature and self-regulated learning
usually distinguishes between internal
and external factors so that's like you
know some people just left because the
content is irrelevant so it's just
irrelevant or some people you know don't
have time so there are ways to identify
this in precourse surveys and so I think
this could help kind of you know sort of
cut out a a a you know a slice of
students that really are nonen amenable
for intervention and just focus on those
you know with internal factors so that's
one thing um the other I
think
uh I forgot sorry technical difficulties
of the brain I get it
too oh so so yeah so the other thing is
you know with this High fraction of
people who intend to complete the course
at the beginning but don't uh I feel
that muks are you know apart from the
content that we're actually delivering
uh they serve an excellent platform for
mentoring students workit so if you know
that something is useful for you on the
long run and uh I believe that because
of your you know work habits your habits
of self motivating yourself your
volitional control of yourself how much
you know you try to say okay this is
useful I have to overcome my my desire
to go on Facebook and Twitter and
actually save some time to go and do the
moo I think this in itself if we look at
it as something we can use muks as a
vehicle for changing this trait in
students it's well worth the research
and the money that goes into it yeah so
that actually reminded me of something
that I heard I think in the previous or
previous previous section where someone
was talking about uh or maybe it was
during the plenary session this morning
I don't remember but there there was
this discussion about the importance of
uh of having a community and feeling
like you belong to a community and for
me this is one of the really exciting
things about the discussion forms is
because that's one of the places where
this happens and so trying to find a way
to Foster this as a way of building up
people's self sort of internal
motivation I think is really exciting I
I I totally
agree one last comment before our last
activity
here okay so I would have kind of a meta
question so I'm from a European Muk
platform and we are we also surveyed
like 400,000 students and um the
procedure seems always to be to um to
have like um segments of students then
uh performance indicators and then um
most of the researchers um find
correlations and um perhaps one or two
researchers already found um
interventions to manipulate the segments
and make it better but what's the the
whole goal of it um do we in the end if
we find out something do we really want
to intervene on everybody and uh and um
make the performance indicators better
like this at least yeah I'm not sure so
what's your well I think anyway that the
answer to that question is it depends um
kind to my ear my first point about how
when the way we answer some of those
questions that keep me up at night um is
very dependent upon the goals of the
institution in delivering a Muk in
general there's no standard reason why
we're all in this room right we're all
here for different reasons our
institutions are doing mukes for
different reasons and I think that those
different reasons can and should drive
the research we're doing and can and
should drive the way in which we design
the courses uh I don't know if either of
you think that there's an easy answer to
his question but I think it's actually a
hard
one w i i don't think there's any way to
answer a question with an easy answer
but um I can give you an example that um
so from our L study one of the findings
that if you're a student you're more
interested in just the novelty of the
mood platform um you're less likely to
be completers so what does that mean for
you as you know instructor or designers
well um if you have a goal to say I want
to you know improve improve our
completion rates or you want to say I
want to have a more specific learning
groups of students that that they know
what our course is going to offer and
that they have a sort of correct
anticipation of their weekly commitment
even before they start the course if you
want a cohort of students like that you
might be able to just you know emphasize
you know before you you open the course
saying that our course is um you know
requires six six hours a month work and
you have to have specific PR
prerequisite
if you emphasize that much more uh in a
distinctive way maybe it's a it's a
better way to filter through um so you
can get students more
engaged all right so now I want to keep
our microphone Runners on their feet
because what I'd like everyone to do is
is just you know raise your hand and in
30 seconds tell us one thing that you're
going to do tomorrow or on Monday as a
result of this session or one question
that you're going to bring back to your
research team I'm going to take not
notes and I'll share them on that
PowerPoint presentation uh we don't have
the slides up anymore but we'll get it
to you one way or another and you can
you can uh see the notes of what other
people are going to do um when they get
back so what's what's one thing you're
going to do or one question you're going
to ask your team when you get
back or was this completely valueless
that's
acceptable it wasn't completely
valueless so um
I think what we're going to do is really
try and clarify for ourselves why we're
doing the mukes because that's what we
need to do in order to be able to define
success metrics and it's been very clear
to us for a while that completion is not
answering our questions um so it's going
to be really focusing on on
clarifying more um meaningful metrics
sure
great other next
steps I'm going to add to one uh
question to our motivation survey so not
to ask people um on the intention to
complete the course but on the
self-confidence to complete a
course good so yeah so I think for in
terms of like the next step for like our
re like for our research team is more to
like trying to trying to build up like a
Muk uh like a m uh collaborative
community and to and also to bring up
all the all the researchers together
especially the ones who are trying to to
tackle with all the C data and and other
kind of like very ambiguous stuff so
that's that's a
challenge I got something to say uh I
think so I I also I'm here for the
conference I'm just volunteering but I
think uh as someone who's working on
launching a Muk I'm going to take back
and make sure we're addressing the types
of students that maybe just want to
access the content as an educator as
someone who wants to review the material
and making sure that completion rates
aren't the only thing that I'm looking
at yeah
yay uh so I'll add something so uh there
was actually a Twitter discussion during
uh some of the presentations and one of
the things that came up that I'd like to
do is maybe ask students not why are you
taking this moo but what does success
mean to you uh in the context of this
Muk so that we can evaluate people
according to sort of their own
rubrics more on the technical side but I
I read your papers I I I you know I I
initially seem to love the PSL framework
H so one thing I'm going to look into is
you know how can we use it and how does
it compare to work we have done
before we can help if you want thank
you
um I have the last comment on so for me
um my next step I would want to to
know um what we can do about
non-completers because if we were to
build you know a a formula or a model to
assess any given moo that of course
we're going to look at non-completers so
for example um a student you know comes
in just you know third week and look at
one video and complete one task and very
happy and he or she just laugh how do we
you know infer that maybe from the lock
data from discussion forums how do we
factor that kind of um good feedback
into our assessment model or even not
really so good feedback how do we can
combine all of these um engagement
patterns to assess um imuk whether
whether a moo is doing a good job or
not I hope that um if someone mentions
something that they're going to do as
the next step and you're interested in
the same thing you go find them right
now because we're done thank
you